a new york-based company planting some
roots here in southern nevada it's
called tapestry building a west coast
distribution center in north las vegas
our hector mejia joining us live now
near tropical parkway and the 215 and
hector the good news here this company
is bringing hundreds of jobs
that is correct heather good afternoon
400 full-time jobs in fact by the year
2029 and just take a look
construction broke ground earlier this
morning we've learned it was all in the
works for almost a year
itself has a leading global house of
modern luxury brands which include coach
and kate spade new york the future 789
thousand square foot facility will be a
west coast distribution site for the new
york based company it will hold as many
as 4 million units in inventory for both
retail and online sales we are thrilled
to be here in north las vegas this is
our first ground up facility that we've
built in 25 years we expect to build
this facility and then continue to grow
into it this new fulfillment facility is
going up near tropical parkway and the
215 in an area that's close to other
distribution sites including amazon
north las vegas mayor john lee says the
addition is continuing with the efforts
to diversify our local economy through
about six different industrial sites
going on right now not including the
apex industrial site that's actually
moving forward even quicker than we
perceive they're doing big things here
we've got some distribution we've got
manufacturing we're diversifying now
what these big buildings are holding
there's a lot of money being pumped in
north las vegas
and the plan is to have the center open
and operational by early 2023 reporting
live in north las vegas hector mejia
live local now